it's wedding season time to pop the
champagne get on your dancing shoes and
shell out thousands and thousands of
dollars every year there are two and a
half million weddings in the US and it's
not news to anyone they're expensive the
global wedding industry is worth 300
billion dollars and an American couple
spends an average of 31 thousand dollars
on their wedding that cost can be more
expensive depending on where you live
Manhattanites you've got the highest
price tag the average wedding there cost
seventy six thousand dollars live in
Utah you're looking at the cheapest
average but it's still fifteen thousand
dollars
we know the wedding industrial complex
is draining our wallets but when you
consider all the excess and leftovers
what's the real cost of wedding waste
let's start with the flowers unless the
wedding is happening in California where
there are year-round flower farms
wedding florists are likely importing
most of their products which means that
a lot of energy is wasted in
transporting and keeping those delicate
chemically treated buds fresh then there
are the rings mining enough gold for one
wedding ring generates 20 tons of
contaminated waste which often ends up
in lakes and oceans and gold and diamond
mines around the world are often home to
abuse and labor violations how romantic
oh and the diamond engagement ring
tradition it's completely made up by the
way Thank You DeBeers I'll be eating
ramen for the next three months to pay
it off and food you've got to feed your
guests an average American Wedding
produces 500 pounds of garbage most of
it from food and food prep that's the
same amount of garbage that an average
American throws away in almost four
months which is also pretty wasteful but
the United States isn't alone countries
around the world are dealing with
massive amounts of waste when it comes
to weddings India is a country long
known for its lavish weddings that last
days and serve hundreds of guests the
former food Minister estimated 1/5 of
all wedding food is tossed out
he called it criminal waste in the city
of Bangalore alone 943 tons of wedding
food is wasted every year Pakistan had
the same problem so they passed a law in
2006 limiting wedding feasts to one main
dish and wedding crashers don't help in
Afghanistan grooms have to prepare to
feed sometimes hundreds of uninvited
guests who just show up aside from the
unavoidable food waste this also often
leads to crushing debt what a way to
begin a life together it's gotten so bad
that the Afghan parliament is trying to
pass a law that will cap the number of
wedding guests to 500 where economies
are booming wedding waste is especially
bad like in Nigeria where opulent
weddings see upwards of a thousand
guests talk about a seating arrangement
nightmare entrepreneurs there have begun
offering everything from VIP toilets to
drink delivery service a must in a
country that now drinks
champagne than anyone outside of France
so what's a bride or groom to do ask
your caterer to donate uneaten food be
simple use electronic invites to save on
paper consider buying antique jewelry or
a vintage gown and instead of shipping
in those perfect roses use local in
season flowers or you could elope
there's always that in the 1960s only
around one in ten adults over 25
preferred the bachelor life that's more
than doubled so why do so many fold